♪♪
SO THE MYTH IS, CAN A SURGICAL
LASER LIGHT A FART ON FIRE?
Narrator:
AND TO GO FULL-SCALE,
RACHEL, VALERIE, AND JESSE
ARE RE-CREATING
AN ALL-TOO-ACCURATE
OPERATING-ROOM SCENARIO.
WE ARE GOING FULL-SCALE,
AND THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
BEHIND ME.
OUR PATIENT HAS HAD
HIS CHEST CUT OUT.
ON TOP OF THAT IS A SCREEN,
AND ON TOP OF THE SCREEN
IS A BUNCH OF MEAT
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW, OPERATIONS
INCLUDE A LOT OF MEAT
IN THE FORM OF HUMANS.
WE ARE GOING TO PIPE OUR FART IN
UNDERNEATH THAT MEAT
SO IT AERATES UP THROUGH,
AND WE'RE GONNA DRESS
ALL AROUND IT
WITH A WHOLE BUNCH
OF SURGICAL TOWELS --
THE MOST VIGOROUS FUEL
WE WERE ABLE TO TEST IN SCALE.
HOPEFULLY THIS WHOLE PLACE WILL
BE ON FIRE IN A FEW MINUTES.
Narrator:
SO THE TEAMS SCRUB UP,
AND MASTER BUILDER JESSE
PLUMBS IN THE PATIENT
TO RELEASE GAS
FROM THE INTESTINAL AREA,
SIMULATING AN ACCIDENTAL
COLON PUNCTURE
AND PREMATURE EJECTION
OF FLATUS.
NOW BUSTER'S JUST LIKE ADAM --
FULL OF FARTS.
Narrator:
BUT UNLIKE ADAM,
THERE'S NO RISK
OF BUSTER FAILING TO PERFORM
WHEN THE PRESSURE'S ON.
-YOU GOT ONE?
-I THINK SO.
OH, IT'S A LITTLE,
TINY ONE.
NO.
NOTHING.
Narrator: AND IN ADDITION TO THE
CONTROLLED INFLOW OF BACKFLOW,
THE TEAM IS ADDING ONE
FURTHER INGREDIENT TO THE MIX.
OXYGEN.
EVERY OPERATING ROOM IS
AN OXYGEN-RICH ENVIRONMENT,
SO WE'RE GONNA ADD OXYGEN
IN THE MIX
AND SEE IF WE GET
A BETTER RESULT.
Narrator: BUSTER'S MASK WILL BE
LEAKING OXYGEN,
REALISTICALLY ENRICHING
THE SOON-TO-BE COMBUSTIBLE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND WITH
THE EXPERIMENTAL PLATFORM
MATCHING THE MYTHICAL SETUP
AS ACCURATELY AS POSSIBLE,
IT'S GO-TIME.
ALL RIGHT. THIS IS CATASTROPHIC
OPERATING-ROOM FARTS.
OKAY. I'M GOING TO
LOWER IN THE LASER.
OKAY, LASER STARTING UP
IN 3...
2...1.
WE GOT FIRE
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
-RIGHT.
-OKAY.
TURN ON THE GAS.
COUNT IT IN.
LETTING IT RIP
IN 3...
2...1.
[ LOUD BANG ]
[ CHEERING ]
-EXPLOSION!
-THAT WAS A THING.
SOMETHING HAPPENED.
-SOMETHING HAPPENED!
[ Laughing ]
THAT WAS REALLY COOL.
[ LOUD BANG ]
Narrator:
THE THERMAL CAMERA WILL REVEAL
IF THE ADDITION OF THE OXYGEN
CAUSED AN EXPLOSION.
THIS IS THE THERMAL.
-OH!
-WOW.
-OH, THAT WAS BIG.
-THAT WAS COOL.
DO IT AGAIN.
Rachel: ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
DID YOU SEE THAT?
FIRE ENGULFED THE ENTIRE
PATIENT'S CHEST THERE
FOR A SECOND.
I MEAN, REALLY,
IF THAT HAPPENED,
YOU'D RUN FOR YOUR LIFE.
I MEAN, I WOULD CALL THAT
EXPLOSION.
Narrator: BUT IS IT ENOUGH
TO CONFIRM THE MYTH?
THIS ONE'S UP FOR DEBATE.
HOW DO WE WANT TO
CALL THIS?
PERSONALLY, I THINK
IT'S CONFIRMED.
NO WAY.
I TOTALLY DISAGREE.
THIS IS BUSTED.
WE NEVER GOT OUR LASER
TO IGNITE OUR FART.
WE ALWAYS HAD TO INTRODUCE
A NEW HEAT SOURCE.
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
BUT OUR SETUP
IS TOTALLY REALISTIC.
I MEAN, WE HAVE
THE MEDICAL-GRADE LASER,
ADAM'S SYNTHETIC FART,
AND THE OXYGEN
IN THE AIR AROUND IT,
AND I TOTALLY SAW A FIRE.
AND WE GOT A KABOOM.
OKAY. GIVEN THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE TO TRAVEL OUTSIDE
THE CONFINES OF AN OPERATING
ROOM TO ACHIEVE THIS,
I'M WILLING TO CALL IT
PLAUSIBLE.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
PLAUSIBLE IT IS.
-PLAUSIBLE.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET THIS GUY TO THE O.R.
[ SIREN WAILS ]
♪♪
THESE KIND OF STORIES
ARE TRICKY --
ONES WHERE THE PREMISE
IS SENSATIONAL,
BUT THE EXECUTION REQUIRES
THIS PERFECT STORM
OF ALL THESE
DISPARATE ELEMENTS
TO COME TOGETHER
TO CREATE THE CATASTROPHE.
THEY'RE ALWAYS BUTT-KICKERS,
AND THIS ONE IS NO EXCEPTION.
THE GUYS HAD TO GO DOWN
ALL SORTS OF WRONG TURNS
TO GET TO THE FINAL RESULT,
BUT THEY DID,
AND MY FINAL TAKEAWAY FROM THIS
IS THAT MY FARTS
ARE STILL POTENT.